Hallo, Lalle ist meine Name, ich bin eine der Stationen-Estern und heute bin ich für Sie zuständig.
Jetzt würde ich dieses Analyse-Gespräch durchfüllen, wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Und jetzt werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Personen stellen, danach sprechen wir sofort über Ihr Aktuellen beschreiben.
Okay.
Und, wie war Ihr Name?
Mein Name ist Magdalena Schmidt.
Magdalena Schmidt.
Schmidt mit double T am Ende.
Double T am Ende, okay.
Und S-C-H-M-I-T.
Genau, S-C-H-M-I-T.
Double T, okay.
Frau Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, noch bin ich 56, im Juni werde ich 57.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 11.06.66.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 Meter.
68.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ich 79 kg.
79 kg.
Okay.
Und, was fühlt Sie zu uns?
Warum wurde der Arzt aufgesucht?
Ja, wissen Sie, mein rechter Arm ist mit einmal so geschwollen.
Und der tut mir auch weh.
Und ich habe so das Gefühl, so als ob der spannend,
als ob der wirklich auch ein bisschen dicker ist
und als ob der so prall ist und sich auch ein bisschen warm
und schmerzhaft anfühlt.
Und da habe ich gedacht, das ist mir so unheimlich,
da komme ich jetzt doch mal zu Ihnen.
Okay.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Wäsche erwarten?
Ja, das habe langsam angefangen.
Da habe ich gedacht, da ist vielleicht ein bisschen Muskelkater,
aber das wird gar nicht besser, sondern eher schlimmer.
Es wird immer schlimmer.
Und wenn Sie genau etwas sagen wollten,
ja, seit ein paar Wochen, oder?
Seit einigen Tagen.
Und ja, Sie haben eine Gartenarbeit gemacht
und danach diese Bische werden angefangen.
Wenn ich nicht verletzt bin, aber.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wenn ich nicht verletzt habe,
dann habe ich ja keine Elimine, denn dann böle erst dann.
Und ja, haben Sie sich verletzt bei der Gartenmauer?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht verletzt.
Nein, nein, nein.
Und mit einem Mal mit der Arm aber so rot und warm
und tut weh.
Ich habe den auch gar nicht mehr jetzt gut bewegen.
Also das fühlt sich irgendwie gar nicht gut an.
Und deswegen habe ich gedacht,
muss ich dringend mal zu Ihnen kommen.
Und ja, diese Schmerzen,
strahlen Sie irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, das ist eigentlich auf den Arm beschränkt.
Ja.
Und ja, ertreten Sie auf beim Bewegen
oder ja, in der Ruhe auch haben Sie sich manchmal.
Nein, Sie sind eigentlich auch in Ruhe da.
Vor allen Dingen dieses, dieses, dieses Spällungsgefühl,
dieses Spannungsgefühl ist auch in Ruhe da.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass der Arm schwer ist.
Dass ich den also, dass der,
dass der, ja, wie so eine pralle Wurst ist.
Mhm, Herr Oberarm oder Unterarm?
Eigentlich eher der Oberarm.
Der Oberarm.
Mhm.
Und okay.
Und ja, er hat die,
die, die, die Schwälzung,
herum um die Schultergelenk oder?
Also ich denke eher Oberarm
und das reicht dann runter bis in den Unterarm.
Aber Schwerpunkt, würde ich sagen, ist im Oberarm.
Da ist ja auch mehr so weiches Gewebel.
Mhm.
Und ja, ist schon, ja, der Hard ist amischen,
ja, haben Sie schon Verfälbungen gemacht?
Ich bin schon gerötet.
Ja, Sie sind ein bisschen rötlich und,
und eben so stramm.
Mhm.
Und beim, beim Berühren, ja, ist es sehr schmerzhaftig?
Dann tut es auch weh, ja, ja, klar.
Ich schlafe auch nachts nicht gut,
weil das natürlich, wenn ich da, da drauf liege oder so,
das geht nicht gut.
Und wenn ich mich dann umdrehe, dann geht es wieder.
Aber eigentlich brauche ich so ein Kissen,
um den Arm da richtig hinzulegen.
Mhm.
Ja, fühlen Sie sich auch muskulisch schwer oder,
äh,
wie kann ich kribbeln oder gefühlungslos?
Nein, krimmel tut es eigentlich nicht.
Krimmel tut es nicht.
Mhm.
Würde ich nicht sagen, nee.
Und haben Sie auch keine Muskulischewache in diesem Arm?
Ja, ich bewege den jetzt halt nicht,
weil es weh tut, so.
Mhm.
Ich schoen den jetzt.
Okay.
Und bei der Hände, äh, ja,
die sind ein bisschen kalter geworden,
oder?
Die Hände sind nicht,
nee, Kälter würde ich sagen, sind die nicht, nee.
Mhm.
Okay.
Aber mir ist auch gefallen,
dass die Ringe auch ein bisschen enger sitzen, ne?
Also ich krieg die Ringe nicht runter.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und äh,
ja, diese, diese, äh, rechter Arm ist schon,
haben Sie sich schon überwärmt gesagt,
haben Sie sich schon ihre Fieber schon gemessen?
Fieber habe ich nicht gemessen, nee.
Glaubt nicht, dass ich Fieber hab, so, nee.
Nur der Arm fühlt sich ein bisschen heiß an.
Okay.
Und äh, so,
haben Sie sich schon in den letzten Zeit
ungewirrt operto zugenommen?
Ja, ich hab ein bisschen zugenommen in letzter Zeit.
Äh, nur 2 Kilo in den letzten, im letzten halben Jahr.
Aber ein bisschen schwanktes Gewicht ja immer.
Okay.
Und äh, wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Oh, meistens ist der ganz gut.
Mhm.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder
Wasserlassen beim Wasserlassen?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Nachtscheweis oder...
Nee, ich finde es natürlich nicht nachts, nee, nee, nee.
Haben Sie Schlafstörung?
Nein, also jetzt habe ich nicht gut geschlafen,
weil mir der Arm wehgetan hat,
aber ansonsten kann ich wohl schlafen.
Mhm, okay.
Und ja, haben Sie schon mal endgeltwische Werding gehabt?
Nein.
Ja, haben Sie bei der, bei der, dieser Gartenaarbeit
irgendwie ja einen zicken Stich gemerkt?
Nein, es ist ja Winter,
jetzt kommen keine, also ich hab keinen Stich gemerkt,
hab auch keinen, hab mich eigentlich auch nicht verletzt.
Vielleicht ein bisschen mehr angestrengt,
jetzt hat man ja lange nichts gemacht im Garten
und jetzt hat man halt ein bisschen mehr mal den Arm bewegt,
als man sonst nicht macht.
Und ja, leiden Sie unter Morgenssteifigkeit
bei den Gelenken oder so?
Nein, weil wir sind nicht, nein, nein.
Haben Sie auch die Selberie mal, oder?
Nee, Römer ist nicht bekannt, nee.
Mhm, und leiden Sie an gründlichen Erkrankungen?
Ja, also ich hab ein bisschen hohem Blutdruck
und ich hab auch ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfeldwerte,
aber was eben vielleicht wichtig ist,
ich hatte, vor ja, ist jetzt schon 14 Jahre her,
hatte ich eine Brustoperation.
Und weswegen?
Ja, wegen den 7 Brustkrebs.
Wegen der Brustkrebs, ja.
Okay.
Und ich bin damals halt behandelt worden,
und ich fühlte jetzt ausgeheilt.
Das war aber vor 14 Jahren.
Vor 14 Jahren, mhm.
Und ja, wissen Sie, welche Brustkrebs haben Sie?
Nein, ich weiß nur, dass da operiert worden ist
und ganz kurz bestrahlt worden, aber sonst nichts.
Und ja, Krebsnachsorgeuntersuchungen haben Sie schon...
Sag ich immerhin, ja, ja klar.
Mhm, mhm.
Und wann war Ihr letztes Kontroll?
Oh, ja, die liegt jetzt ein bisschen zurück.
Das ist jetzt fast ein Jahr her.
Fast ein Jahr her.
Und ja, war damals alles in Ordnung?
Ja, ja.
Und jetzt haben Sie acht Beschwerden bei dem Brust?
Ja, ist ja nicht mehr da.
Also, mhm.
Hat Geräut und irgendwie Schwellung oder so?
Nee, eine Schwellung habe ich da jetzt nicht mit dem der Arm ist geschwollt.
Mhm, mhm, okay.
Und nehmen Sie regelnmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, also, ich nehme wegen des Blutdrucks,
nehme ich halt Rastik und Blutdruck.
Ich nehme wegen des Blutdrucks, nehme ich halt Rastik.
Dann nehme ich Konkurr fünf,
eine morgens.
Und dann nehme ich noch Diowan,
160 eine morgens.
160.
Und dann habe ich noch ein Bedarfsmedikament.
Also, wenn ich, wenn ich im Frühling Häuschnupfen habe,
also so, du Polnallergie, dann nehme ich Cetirizin.
Mhm, bei Bedarfs.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und ja, diese Brust-OP, werste Seite war das?
Die rechte Seite.
Die gleichen Seite.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und ja, das war einzige Operation?
Oder hat sie schon wieder operiert worden?
Ich habe, im letzten Jahr habe ich rechts eine neue Hüfte bekommen.
Und ja, das ist jetzt schon vier Jahre her.
Da hatte ich eine Myom-Operation,
also eine Uterus-Operation wegen Myom.
Mhm.
Und ja, ist ganze Uterus, Uterus schon entfärbt,
gewarnt, das schon entfärbt?
Nee, die haben nur das Myom entfernt.
Okay.
Und das war letztes Jahr?
Nee, das ist schon vier Jahre her.
Ja, das ist schon vier Jahre her.
Letztes Jahr war die Hüfte-Operation.
Mhm.
Und ja, das ist ja schon, die Hüfte-Prote,
haben sie schon bekommen.
Genau, ja.
Okay.
Das war rechte Seite oder linke Seite?
Rechte Seite, ja.
Rechte Seite.
Haben sie allergie?
Das war nicht rechte Seite zu sein, ja.
Ja, das war rechte Seite.
Schade.
Haben sie allergie?
Ja, also ich habe so ein bisschen,
so, so, Heuschnupf-Schein.
Gegen Prolenzen oder?
Gegen Prolenzen, ja.
Brauchen Sie?
Nee, geraucht habe ich zum Glück nie.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich habe das auch.
Ach, hin und wieder mal.
Also, ja, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt,
oder malen Glas Wein oder im Sommer,
wenn es warm ist, malen eine Flasche Bier,
aber wirklich nicht regelmäßig.
Mhm.
Und mit dieser Frage nicht nehmen Sie persönlich,
das ist eine Rutschung-Erfrage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Traugen?
Mit Drogen.
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich wirklich keine Erfahrung.
Mein Vater ist sehr früh gestorben,
der hatte ganz früh einen Herzinfarkt,
aber meine Mutter lebt noch
und die ist eigentlich ganz gesund.
Von der habe ich wohl diese Hüftprobleme geerbt,
die hat auch schon relativ in frühen Jahren
ein neues Hüftgelenk bekommen
und die hat auch ein bisschen hohen Bebruch.
Und haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe Geschwester ja mein Bruder,
der ist auch nicht gesund.
Der ist auch nicht gesund.
Der hatte vor vielen Jahren einen Herzinfarkt
und aber den hatte er eigentlich ganz gut überstanden,
der ist gut behandelt worden.
Und bei meiner Schwester, da hat man tatsächlich
vor einem Jahr auf Großgrätschwest gestellt.
Und die ist noch in der Behandlung.
Nein.
Ja, arbeiten Sie noch?
Ja, ja, ich bin Reiseverkehrskaufrau
und arbeite jetzt nicht mehr Vollzeit,
aber so 20 Stunden in der Woche mache ich noch.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe sogar schon Enkelkinder.
Also ich habe einen Sohn und zwei Töchter
und drei Enkelkinder.
Die Familie wird immer größer.
Ja, alle sind gesund?
Die sind alle gesund, ja.
Ich hoffe auch, dass das so bleibt.
Ja, hoffen wir auch.
Ja, leben Sie alleine?
Nein, ich lebe mit meinem Mann natürlich.
Kinder sind schon aus dem Haus.
Okay, leiden Sie einen untersteht Stress?
Stress auch nö, nicht wirklich.
Arbeit macht mir Spaß.
Und mein Mann macht mir auch kein Ärger.
Ja, das ist ja gut.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Da müsste ich jetzt lügen.
Also so regelmäßig Sport mache ich nicht.
Ich nehme das zwar immer wieder vor, Gymnastik zu machen
und auch mal wieder mehr Fahrrad zu fahren.
Aber ich mache halt ein bisschen Gartenarbeit.
Und jetzt im Sommer, wenn das Wetter besser wird,
dann fahre ich auch wieder mehr mit dem Fahrrad.
Okay.
Und eine Frage für diese Brustoperation.
Und bei diesem Operation ist Ihre Lymphknoten
bei den rechten Seite.
Ist es schon auch entfernt oder bleiben noch weiter?
Die sind auf alle Fälle ent, also da hat man was untersucht.
Das weiß ich.
Die hat man untersucht.
Okay, aber bei dieser Operation
ist die Lymphknoten noch nicht entfernt.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob die entfernt worden sind
oder ob man die nur untersucht hat.
Aber ich denke mal, die hat man rausgenommen wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube, die hat man rausgenommen.
Ich denke mal, die hat man rausgenommen wahrscheinlich.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Okay, dann untersuchen wir das auch.
Okay, war schon mit.
Ich habe schon alle meine Frage gestellt.
Ja?
Wenn Sie etwas fragen möchten,
ja, kann ich gerne antworten.
Ich möchte natürlich wissen,
wieso ist der Arm mit einmal so dick
und was kann man dagegen machen?
Das kann ja so nicht bleiben.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe eine Verlacht darauf.
Aber das zu sprechen, ist ein bisschen früh.
Erst machen wir die Körper, die untersuchen,
dann der War-Untersuchung
und wieder mindestens Otrachal
und wieder diese Brustkontrolle,
sollen wir durchführen, dann können wir ausführlich sprechen.
Aber eine Lymphgefäße verschlüsselt
kann auch in Frage kommen.
Und was kann man dagegen machen?
Das sehen wir.
Viel, viel, viel Adioteterapie kann uns helfen.
Wenn diese Arm schon entzündet ist,
können wir Adioterapie anfangen.
Ah, ja, okay.
Gut, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Und jetzt werde Sie untersuchen.
Dann werde ich mit meinen Oberarztin sprechen.
Dann können wir über alles sprechen.
Okay, gut.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Ja, natürlich bin ich geimpft. Klar, ich bin gegen Corona.
Gibt es einige Fragen, die Schmerzintestät?
Genau, hat er nicht gefragt.
Die Schmerzintestät nicht so schlimm, beschreibt sie mir 6 von 10.
Was ist für sie eine schmerzhafte Schwellung?
Das ist ja kombiniert. Es ist eine schmerzhafte Schwellung.
Und Pralung?
Eine Pralung.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzhafte Schwellung.
Pral, Sie haben gesagt, nicht Pral.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, der Arm fühlt sich prall an.
Prall an, was bedeutet prall an?
Wenn Sie einen Luftballon aufpumpen, dann ist der erst schlapp.
Und wenn Sie der Luft reintun, dann ist der prall.
Oder ein Ball.
Okay, ich sehe.
Dann gibt er nicht mehr nach.
Okay, dagegen nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein.
Nein, Sie haben noch nichts eingenommen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben eine Schwellung in Oberarm.
Aber könnte Sie mir etwas genauer beschreiben,
wo befindet diese Beschleunigung unter der Achselbühle
oder vor der Seite von diese Oberarm?
Sie merkt das, dass der ganze Oberarm rundherum geschwollen ist.
Sie beschreibt, nicht dezidiert eine Schwellung in der Achselbühle.
Okay, okay, danke schön.
Das wäre sicherlich etwas,
was man dann jetzt in der körperlichen Untersuchung nachziehen müsste.
Dass man dann genau guckt, wo die Schwellung schluckalisiert ist.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass es eine wundere Abschulfung gibt?
Hat er gefragt, habe ich gesagt, ich habe mich nicht verletzt.
Und ich habe nichts gesehen.
Aber auch da, klar, muss er natürlich gucken.
Und zwar eben auch an so Geschichten.
Sie kennen das vielleicht so trockene Stellen zwischen den Fingern.
Oder eben ganz kleine Verletzungen an den Händen,
wäre bei Gartenarbeit nicht ungewöhnlich.
Oder auch im Nagelbett, dass man da irgendwie sowas hat.
Das sind oft Verletzungen, die einem gar nicht bewusst sind.
Da muss man sehr genau gucken dann.
Vielleicht Ihre Arzt, die Frauen, Sie haben gesagt,
da ist ja ein Ring getragen.
Ja.
Ja, ich trage Ringe und die passen nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, da ist ja eine Ring getragen.
Betroffene Hand, das steht.
Ja, ja.
Hat Ihre Frauen nicht gesagt,
die Hände müssen Sie beachten.
Das ist doch schon so lange her.
Ja, also das ist schon so lange her.
Erst habe ich die nicht getragen,
aber jetzt habe ich die dann wieder aufgetan,
sie passen ja wieder.
Können wir anfangen, Arzt, zu gehen?
Ja, gut.
Okay.
Hallo Frau, ich habe heute eine Patientin aufgenommen.
Ja.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, würde ich gerne vorstellen.
Haben Sie die schon stationär aufgenommen?
Noch nicht, aber ich würde das empfehlen.
Okay, dann schauen wir mal.
Was haben Sie denn gesehen?
Frau Schmidt, ja, 56-jährige Patienten.
Ja, ich stelle dabei uns vor wegen der Schwedung
an den Rehten oberarm.
Und ja, auch berichtet, berichtet Sie über die Rehten,
wo wir auch ein bisschen schmerzhafter geworden sind und ein bisschen fühlt sie diese extremtät
oder ein extremtät ein bisschen überwärmt und gerötet.
Sie ist vor 14 Jahren wegen einer Mama-Catsnum schon operiert worden in der gleichen Seite.
Ob die Axel-Lemfknotten bei diesen Operationen entfernt ist weiß ich genau nicht.
Die bestewarte Bestät seit ein paar Tagen nach einem Gartenarbeit angefangen berichtet sie.
In den letzten 6 Monaten hat sie 2 Kilogramm zugenommen.
Ansonsten, vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig und sie leite an eine Arterie der Hypertonie
und Hypocholesteranämie und blädenmäßige Medikamente, Konkof 5, 1 Morgen und Diuran 160, 1 Morgen
und gegen Holstein und Neufn bekommen sie bei bedarfischer Zittern sind.
Und einmal vor einem, letztes Jahr oder vor einem Jahr eine Hüfte-Peperates-Operation
wurde durchgeführt bei ihr und mir mit Tommy auch vor 4 Jahren und er trinke gelegentlich Alkohol
Ansonsten erlaubt keiner Aufwähligkeit und ja, Podinosa war ihr schon bekannt,
weil der Familienanamnese ja ihr Vater ist schon ein junger Alter wegen einem ja gerade Infarktes gestorben
und ja, ihre Mutter ist schon gesund und nicht gesund eigentlich, leidet an Arterie der Hypertonie
und einer ja, wieder Hüfte-Pep-Operation wurde auch durchgeführt bei ihr Mama.
Weiter, Mutter, okay.
Sie arbeitet als Reisefekerkauf-Frau und eigentlich ja, sie hat keine stressige Art
und in der sozialen Bereich kann ich nichts ja auch Fähigkeit berichten.
Okay, und bei der Bruder ist schon einmal ja gerade Infarktes schon vor 4 Jahren bekannt
und ihr Schwester auch vor einem Jahr eine Mama-Catzen um ist schon diagnostiziert.
Eigentlich ja, ich habe noch sage Untersuchungen regelmäßig bis letztes Jahr durchgeführt
und letzter Untersuchung war auch unauffällig bei Frauische mit, aber ja, ich denke auch einer
ja, resistive Mama-Catzen um als Verlachjagd musste ich mit ja, Liftnoten befragen, aber ja,
Was, was könnte denn Alter einer Tief sein?
Ja, nach der Gartenarbeit hat die Bischöwarten angefangen und so, ja, viele Leute lernen
Panjetis kann auch infrage bunden oder oder oder oder ja, Muskelverletzungen oder so eine
Resilie auch kann sein.
Ja, genau.
Gut, hat sie was von Verletzungen gesagt?
Nein, sie hat keine Verletzungen gerechnet.
Okay, ja, was machen sie denn jetzt diagnostisch mit ihr?
Ja, diagnostisch, ja, als körperlich untersuchen, ob sie irgendwie ja neurologische Auffälligkeit
oder neurologische Auffälligkeit oder so wie die, wie die.
Ja, wo, was machen sie denn, was machen sie denn bei der körperlichen Untersuchung jetzt zu allererst?
Bevor sie die neurologischen Sachen testen, erst mal gucken sie doch.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, Inspektion, Inspektion bei rechten Oberarm, rechten Extremitäten,
ja, wie die.
Gucken sie nur nach dem rechten Arm?
Natürlich vergleiche ich mit den linken Arm.
Also, umfangsmaße, ne?
Umfangsmaße vergleichen, ja.
Okay, dann.
Was machen sie manuell?
Manuell, ich hab ja Wirklichkeit untersuche ich und kann ich auch so.
Ja, ob die, ob der Oberarm ist schon ja richtig überwärmt ist oder kann ich auch das kontrollieren.
Das ist auch noch interessant, ja, Prüße, genau.
Prüße soll ich auch, ja, Traktasten, so auch ja, Limpknoten soll ich untersuchen, weil ich weiß,
genau, dass sie nach den Limpknoten gucken, das war eigentlich meine Idee, genau.
Gut, ja, und was machen sie sonst weiter für Untersuchung?
Und ja, die betroffenen Mama-Karzmann bei der rechten Seite und ich würde jetzt wieder diese Mama wieder runter suchen und ob die Schwillung
oder eine Masse in diesem Mama ist schon vorhanden, ist sonst nicht mehr ich prüfen.
Ja, und was machen sie da in der Hinsicht operativ?
Einer Mama-Grafee, denke ich.
Aber zunächst mal, was würde man erst mal wahrscheinlich doch für eine Untersuchung machen?
Okay, so, erst, allererst ja Blutuntersuchung, Blutabnahme.
Ja, was untersuchen sie denn im Blut?
Okay, ja, besonders für diesem Fall, wenn ich sage, ja, das fehlt mir nicht ein, genau.
Wie wäre es mit Digimeren?
Ja, natürlich, okay, ja, kann das auch Gefahr Design.
Ja, das ist eine unungewöhnliche Seite.
Lokalisation, aber unungewöhnliche Anerkennung, aber trotzdem kann die Frage kommen immer.
Ja, und auch das Lymphedem kann man sonographisch sehen.
Eine Untersuchung bei diesem Arm.
Gut, ja, also Digimere und natürlich auch Entzündungsparameter, würde man auf alle Fälle gucken.
Und vielleicht auch noch vorsorglich gucken, ob die irgendwie niedrig ist mit dem HB oder so.
Aber ja, vor allen Dingen eben Entzündungswerte und ich denke Digimere würde man machen,
um auszusehsen, dass die vielleicht eine Thrombose in dem Arm hat.
Jo, was Sie tatsächlich nicht gefragt haben, fällt mir dabei gerade ein, ob die hustet.
Das wäre ja auch noch interessant im Zusammenhang mit Ambientrombose und Verdacht auf Lungenembolier.
Das müsste man sicherlich auch noch nachfrage.
Gut, das habe ich noch.
Also Sie untersuchen das Blut, Sie machen die Ultraschall.
Und ja, was können Sie im Ultraschall feststellen?
Sie haben schon den Puls gemessen.
Und auch, er können die Ultraschall ausschließen.
Ja, genau. Wir können gucken, ob die wenenfrei sind.
Ja, und gut, und dann kommt, als nächster Schritt, natürlich wenn wir da also nichts finden,
wäre dann möglicherweise Mammografie oder erforderlich.
Dann würde man tippen, dass sie möglicherweise ein Rezidiv hat, meinen Sie?
Ja, meine Rezidiv.
Ich meine nicht, weil die Symptome nicht eine Metastase, sondern auch eine LCPL oder Phelegmonen.
Ja, aber da hätte man auch, tatsächlich beim Irresipel hätte man auch deutlich erhöhte Entzündungswerte.
Ja, aber die Symptome sind schnell einige Tage, einige Tage LCPL.
Aber lange Zeit, die Symptome sind wichtig.
Aber die Symptome sind keine.
Ja, wobei, was es auch noch sein könnte, wäre eben praktisch, also das würde man aber natürlich im Ultraschall sehen.
Also eine Phelebitis, eine wenen Entzündung.
Phelebitis.
Das wären hier die Differenzialdiagnosen, die hier angegeben waren.
Phelebitis, Lymphedem, tiefer Arm, Wenen, Trombose, Irresipel.
Wobei beim Irresipel wäre ja eben hoch akut, die Rötung festzustellen.
Und man würde eigentlich auch irgendwo eine Eintrittsforte sehen müssen.
Und das ist natürlich etwas, was man bei der Inspektion sehr genau machen muss.
Also ich bin auch so ein Held bei der Gartenarbeit.
Ich sehbel mir da irgendwie immer was kaputt.
Auch wenn man Erbel, also lange Erbel hat, kann irgendwas pieksen und kann durch die Kleidung durchkommen,
irgendein Ästchen oder eine Dornen, was man gar nicht so bemerkt hat.
Und das reicht ja oft schon.
Das reicht oft schon, wenn man diesen vorgeschädigten Arm hat.
Beziehungsweise, das ist halt die Geschichte, dass auch nach einem Mammarkatz,
den um so eine Lymphedem bei starker Belastung kommen kann.
Nach Jahren.
Und also das ist gar nicht ausgeschossen.
Einmal auf den Umweg über ein Irresipel, dass dann das Ädem nachbleibt.
Das kann auch sein, dass einfach durch die akute Überlastung mit einmal ein Arm,
an dem man überhaupt nicht mehr gedacht hat.
Also sie hat ja auch wieder ihre Ringe getragen.
Also für sie war das eigentlich kein Thema mehr.
Der Brustkrebs war schon so lange weg.
Hat den nicht mehr so besonders gut aufgepasst.
Und dann hat sie eben den rechten Arm stark belastet.
Kann sein, dass sie dadurch sich ein Lymphedem eingehandelt hat.
Das wäre nicht auszuschließen.
Gut.
Ja.
Wenn sich jetzt rausstellt, dass sie zum Beispiel eine Phlebitis hat
oder möglicherweise sogar eine tiefe Armwind vom Bose.
Was wäre dann Therapie?
Das ist therapeutisch.
Das ist ja eine Antikorrelation.
Genau.
Und was machen wir noch?
Ja, erst eine Konfliktion,
das ist auch der Arm wickeln.
Den Arm wickeln, genau.
Und langfristig unter Umständen Armstrumpf verordnen.
Aber tatsächlich jetzt zunächst dann bandagieren
und eben eine Antikorrelation einleiten mit Reparieren
und dann gegebenenfalls umstellen.
Ja, und auch einfach Lagerung.
Ja.
Das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Und wenn es eine akute Entzündung ist,
was würde man dann auch dazu machen?
Ja, wenn es eine akute Entzündung ist,
dann werden wir auch eine Antibiotherapie anfangen.
Ah ja, genau.
Und was dann auch sehr angenehm ist, ist Kühlung.
Darf man zwar im Winter nicht dran denken,
aber es ist so, ne?
Ja, auf alle Fälle strumpf.
Ja, würden wir sagen.
Also erst bandagieren, dann muss der Strumpf angepasst werden.
Der muss ja auch so ein bisschen abgeschwollen sein,
damit der Strumpf dann nachher dauerhaft komprimiert.
Und dann muss die eine Weile, müsste sie makomarisiert werden
und eben ihren Strumpf tragen.
Wie lange würden Sie sagen?
Ja, bis zum 6.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und dann, oh, das schreibt man anders,
aber im Prinzip ist es richtig, Lymphtrainage, genau.
Das wäre, wenn sie tatsächlich ein Lymphideum entwickelt hat.
Dann müsste man tatsächlich noch einmal checken,
ob der Brust alles in Ordnung ist,
ob der Lymph zu und ob sich da was verstecht hat.
Und wenn sie tatsächlich ein echtes Lymphideum hat in dem Arm,
dann wäre Lymphtrainage angesagt,
aber auch mit anschließender Kompression.
Ganz wichtig.
Und da gibt es auch eine Unterscheidung
bei einer Venösenarmschwellung.
Würde man einen rundgestrickten Kompressionsstrumpf nehmen.
Und wenn es ein Lymphideum wäre,
würde man einen flachgestrickten Strumpf nehmen.
Der hat dann eine Naht an irgendeiner Stelle.
Aber dieses Material hält ein Lymphideum
eben sehr viel besser zusammen.
Also eine Mama-Katzinom-Patientin mit einem Lymphideum, post-OP,
da macht man keinen rundgestrickten Strumpf,
sondern macht einen flachgestrickten Strumpf,
der eigentlich auch erst angepasst werden darf,
wenn der Arm durch Lymphtrainage dünner geworden ist.
Also man muss den erst abschwellen
und über Bandagierung
und dann kann man den Strumpf ausmachen.
Und wenn es ein Venösesproblem ist,
Flebitis oder Thrombose,
dann würde man eine rundgestrickten Kompression fangen.
Ja.
Ja, Sie merken, das ist mein Lieblingsthema.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein spannender Fall.
Das ist tatsächlich der Bereich,
in dem ich viele Jahre gearbeitet habe.
Nur als Sekretärin, aber ich habe mit so vielen Patienten geredet
und habe so viele Strumpfrezepte geschrieben,
dass ich also, ja, das ist einfach mein Leib- und Magenthema.
Und ich merke das jetzt wieder, wenn ich davon erzähle,
wie mir das am Herzen liegt.
Ja, genau.
Gut.
Ja, ich muss eben kurz sagen,
Ananese war schön.
Und sprachlich, sprachlich,
machen Sie ein bisschen was,
oder ja, die Gefahr ist immer bei dem langen Einsag, hat das?
Sie stellte bei uns vor, sich vorstellen,
ist reflexiv.
Also stellte sich bei uns vor.
Ja, ja.
Und dann haben Sie manchmal in der Satzstellung
ein bisschen Probleme.
Zum Beispiel haben Sie gesagt,
Sie haben gesagt,
ob die Lymphknoten rausgemacht worden sind,
weiß sie genau nicht.
Ja, also Sie weiß es nicht genau.
Sie ist sich nicht ganz sicher.
Also nicht, sie weiß es genau nicht,
sondern sie weiß es nicht genau.
Aber ansonsten,
also Missverständnisse in dem Sinne gab es eigentlich nicht.
Es ist nur so,
dass Sie, ja, man merkt es eben,
dass Sie kein Muttersprachler sind.
Das ist klar, wäre ja auch ein Wunder.
Sie machen manchmal die Satzstellung.
Ja, am Ende merke ich das.
Aber am Ende, ja, das ist schon vorbei.
Ich habe schon das gesagt.
Der Klassiker ist eigentlich immer,
dass im Hauptsatz das Verb an zweiter Stelle steht
und im Nebensatz das Verb hinstellt.
Das sind so die Sachen,
das weiß man aus der Grammatik,
aber man macht es nicht.
Wobei sehr viele Deutsche es auch nicht richtig machen.
Wie oft sage ich einen falschen Satz,
zum Beispiel einen Weilsatz.
Da würde man ja auch,
das ist ein Nebensatz, eine kausale Begründung.
Was weiß ich?
Sie, ich muss jetzt mal ein Beispiel suchen.
Sie trägt ihre Ringe wieder, weil alles wieder gut war.
Und was sagen wir?
Sie trägt die Ringe wieder, weil alles war wieder gut.
Da ist natürlich verkehrt.
Machen wir aber so.
Auch wir Deutschen, wir machen genau diese gleichen Fehler.
Aber ganz häufig ist diese Geschichte,
zum Beispiel,
wir machen gleich eine Untersuchung.
Das ist richtig.
Wenn sie dann aber sagt, danach,
wir machen eine Untersuchung, das ist verkehrt.
Danach machen wir,
weil da vorne noch ein anderes Wort steht.
Und das ist eigentlich auch so ein Klassiker,
wo immer wieder Fehler passieren.
Daran hört man, dass das jemand eben
nicht 100%ig kürb ist in der Sprache.
Ein bisschen darf man das auch hören.
Ein bisschen ist auch charmant.
Gut.
Danke.